we are taking calls at six one seven
eight three zero four seven five zero
we're going to go to our next caller
from the seven eight six area code
caller introduce yourself and tell me
what's on your mind today
oh yeah well I'll start with a barbell
bro nothing wait I think people are
looking wait yeah there we go
now something a car yeah
anybody there seven eight six yes I'm
sorry
yeah pardon me I was I got on the day
when someone crying in there listening
wait are you lifting weights right now
and I was looking at a friend see
youtube video so I don't like that I do
a fitness and I follow a lot of fitness
guys not you I apologize for that
I what's on your mind um I had one
question yeah I am on a progressive but
I want to start on the local level of
government what issues would you gain
that could or should be the most
important that local people that are
running as progresses should be
advocating for pushing for oh it's so
tough to say because if when you're
talking locally different parts of the
country have their employment issues
Riley Florida okay well I don't know
typically here in Miami Florida by the
way
gotcha you're in Miami Florida I don't
know specifically in Miami yes sir I
think the difficulty Pat is we've talked
about the lack of cohesion from
progressives nationally on something
other than Trump and the Republicans are
bad right now and it's understandable
because Trump is such a disaster and I
get that but we've talked about health
care environment something cohesive on
energy national security in a way that
makes sense and is not bigoted and and
whatever the local progressive issues
really very not not even from state to
state but from district to district so
it's tough to come up with a laundry
list like that
well how about focusing on
gerrymandering because of course after
the
census is conducted state legislators
are typically the ones that draw
district lines right and if you change
who the legislators are or form some
sort of independent commission that's a
step in the right direction that's
interesting because gerrymandering is an
issue that is local but it has national
impact in terms of the balance of power
I think that that's interesting but yeah
you know it's very tough because the
issues in Miami Florida that
progressives might be best suited to
work on locally are going to be
drastically different than the issues in
Washington State for example you know
correct no I understand it and you know
as far as most issues I have to give my
representative credit even though she's
a Republican about Illiana a statement
but we would have ongoing issues and on
and on Trump care she loaded against
Trump care and I was I'm gonna put me in
a place where I never wrote her I have
never voted for her but I can't I find
it hard sometimes to say absolutely the
worst things about her she's you know
she's a hyper ethnic with the Cuban
stuff which I think sometimes goes a
little bit too far but what do you mean
by that what do you I'm interested in
that what do you mean she's hyper ethnic
well III she said how do you say it
if you live in harmony and you're an
American person I said it that way an
Anglo person you understand what I'm
talking about when you say hyper Cuban
they can be very their their minority
that has kind of always been current
otherwise demanded a lot of extra things
that other immigrants have never began
I mean delivers the came in American Act
I believe it was in 1962 which give them
Social Security funds and they do the
Ender if they are born in Cuba they
automatically qualify
I think it's on food stamps for snap and
so forth and what you would have and
this would this is what would make so
many people angry in the store and I
understood whether anger was coming from
you would see people that they would
have grandma who is born a camera would
be getting her snap and the next
generation have been ruined the United
States they're made money without a
grandma you would see that number Diana
you and that would as I understood work
part time as a second job as a cashier
at Publix and I would say that and I
would say people behind them there were
anglers that we just get really mad
because these people wouldn't you can
verify with David Pat if you look it up
they could say guy they're going to get
snap and so get there were they were I
don't know if that's ended they used to
get social security payments yeah as
well because it was considered a helping
hand but it was keeping on going and
going got it we were getting this money
yep and get their face similar
generations are in a gown one two
generations or doing okay in the United
States and it just meant it would just
make people very angry
okay I've got a theory on when you talk
about when you talk about Anglos would
like a would an Italian doctor can be
and myself I'm Irish and English and
German descent but again immunizes my
family came fragrance 1688 the currents
my name is Kevin comments by my last
name the people's yeah they did here
they didn't do and for jigna and then
from the 1730's over in Georgia
got it got a mission to Miami okay yeah
point serenades path patient engagement
it's all uh it's complex that's right I
do appreciate a solid I know I can move
on a lot of strong feelings there pad
very very I don't off the rails a little
bit it did go off the rails a little bit
there you